[Music]
the World Cup is underway in Brazil
always an exciting event but there been
a lot of problems down there with
corruption mm-hmm angry protesters
terrible traffic giant cost overruns now
a lot of critics that even question
whether Brazil was ready to host the
World Cup at all we're here to talk
about all the problems is Brazil's World
Cup public relations director Flavio
Paulino let's talk to him mr. Pulido
hello Kalinin como by okay how are
things going down there
things are great couldn't be better okay
what about all the protests down there
look at this picture here's a protester
clearly furious with the soccer
organization FIFA no no no he's having a
great time in that sign FIFA stands for
fun is fantastic I don't think so how
about this photo of people holding signs
that say we don't need the World Cup we
need money for hospitals and education
now now Alcona now those are just kids
who want concert tickets for Brazil's
hottest new band hospitals and education
that is not a bad no sure it is I'm sure
you've heard their hit song stop it okay
I'm cleared I told you to stop because
you clearly had stopped you you just
made that Masana I love the band
hospitals and education you're telling
to tell me you love the way I just sang
your hit song that I didn't just make up
on the spot
your phone didn't even ring airplane
mode okay yeah right what about all the
money that was wasted on brand-new
soccer stadiums including a 300 million
dollar stadium built in the Amazon
rainforest some places broke but it's
being used for four times four games
what are you gonna do with it after that
Oh lots of things it could be a piranha
Convention Center
Shakespeare in the park for frogs or
maybe even a nightclub for snakes women
a nightclub for snakes great idea and
I'm now what song they could dance to
and I meant to say earlier that poster
behind you is very offensive that's my
wife and daughters you're talking about
look it's clear to everyone that you're
in total denial about all the problems
down there counting lighten up let's get
funky with a little hospitals and
education
everybody knows everybody knows it turn
it off just turn it off no no look this
Amazon nightclub snake is loving this
Copeland's don't even live in Brazil
this is globe-trotting party Cobra right
Cobra
are you okay no I'm dead okay
[Applause]